في اوكرانيا اجهضت امنيته حلول السلام مع
بدايه العام الجديد في ظل استمرار القصف
المتبادل بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني
سينما الروسي الذي صعد من هجماته موسكو
وصلت تكثيف قصفها من خلال الاستهداف مناطق
مختلفه في اوكرانيا وتحديدا العاصمه كيا
التي توقفت فيها امدادات الطاقه مؤقتا
هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه قالت ان روسيا
سنه 70 هجوما براجمات الصواريخ خلال 24
ساعه هذا واستهدف القصف الروسي وايضا
مدينه ميكو لايف جنوب البلاد ما تسبب في
دمار وحراره
[موسيقى]
وتعليقا على الهجمات الاخيره في قال الجيش
الروسي من الضربات التي نفذت على مدن
اوكرانيه عده بينها كيف ليله راس السنه
استهدفت منشات لصناعه المسيرات بهدف احباط
هجمات
مباريات مباريات
القوات الروسيه ضربه جويه باسلحه عاليه
الدقه على مرافق صناعيه اوكرانيه تستعمل
في تصنيع وتطوير الطائرات مسيره الهجوميه
والتي تستخدم ضد روسيا كما قامت قوتنا
باستهداف مرافق تخزين الطائرات المسيره
وتعطيل خطتك كيف لتنفيذ الهجمات على روسيا
ومن الواضح ان موسكو بصدر توجيه العمليه
العسكريه نحو مسار جديد من خلال تكثيف
الهجمات في اكثر من منطقه وهو ما اكد عليه
ايضا رئيس الروسي العظيم في خطاب بمناسبه
العام الجديد مشيرا الى ان الحرب ستواصل
هو جاي ما يقراش دنيا
الاعزاء حمل عام 2022 عدد من القرارات
الضروريه الصعبه وذلك بهدف اكتساب السياده
الكامله لروسيا وحده مجتمعه
من اجله من خلال حمايه شعبنا في اراضينا
التاريخيه في المناطق الجديده الروسيه
من الغربه
الروسيه مع الدخول فصل الشتاء سيما في
منطقه
وتبحث القوه الروسيه عن تحقيق ما كسب
اضافيه في الشرق الاوكراني بعد تكبيرها
لخسائر في الجنوب وتحديدا في خرسون التي
استعادت كيف سيطره عليها
على الجانب الاخر القوات الاوكرانيه شنت
هجمات هي الاخرى على بعض الاهداف الروسيه
وتحديدا في مقاطعه لوغانسك حيث نشرت في
ضواحيها صواريخ هاي مارس ويبدو بان العام
الجديد لا يشهد على المدى المنظور توقفا
للمعارك حيث اكد رئيس الاوكراني
بلوميزنسكي ان هذا العام سيكون عاما مصر
في الحرب ضد روسيا مشدده على ان قوه بلاده
ستواصلوا القتال حتى استعاده السيطره على
كافه الاراضي الاخرانيه
من جانبها اذنه السفيره الامريكيه تولد
اوكرانيا الاستهدافات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
قائله في تغريده لها ان الهجوم الروسيه
على اوكرانيا في الساعه الاولى من العام
الجديد عمل جبان مضيفه الان الولايات
المتحده واثقه تماما من انتصار اوكرانيا
في حربها خلال عام 2023